PEGI 16
at the source of all life there is water
on Mars where it is rare water is a
source of conflict struggle and death
since the turmoil there have been
unending wars fought over the possession
of clean water we are the Forgotten
children of Earth trapped in this red
barren wasteland here hell is not a
concept it's our reality and I would
know of course in despair there is hope
some have begun to explore travel even
from corporation to corporation leaving
their loyalties behind
we have organization structure and
inevitably politics we have rulers a
People's Assembly and far removed from
us the dowser the inaccessible face of
abundance and finally there's us the
elite protectors of the people the
spearhead of the army my brothers and
sisters who all share the same special
gift
we are technomancers hello everyone
today we're traveling to Mars with the
sci-fi action RPG the Technomancer you
as Acharya you're about to begin your
journey as the most gifted rookie
Technomancer from abundance a powerful
corporation technomancers are formidable
warriors who harness destructive
electrical powers channeled through
their implants as you create your
character and its appearance you'll
choose your starting talents and
attributes you'll be able to specialize
in one of the three combat stances in
Technomancer or become an all-rounder
whether you become a charismatic warrior
a depth of the Technomancer powers in
the noble staff fighting a shady rogue
dabbling in poison daggers trickery
yourself or a crafty soldier fighting
with a shield and able to upgrade and
improve his weapons there's plenty of
character progression to make you and
your story
your journey starts in off fear capital
of abundance erected from the remains of
the first human settlements in Norfolk
asthma led by a totalitarian regime in
ASC its secret police it is one of the
oldest cities on Mars and one of the
last remaining bastions of humanity but
you'll visit many other locations from
the abandoned earth domes to legendary
cities that you'll be able to travel to
thanks to your trusty Rover
they still want to see your head on a
stick itself
Mars is a dangerous place with deadly
threats lucky in every corner
you'll fight other human survivors such
as the underworld mobs in the slums of a
fear the ASC agents hurting you the
technomancers from rival corporation
Aurora and mutants whose DNA degenerated
after being exposed to solar radiations
and who are now living is outclassed
but you'll also face much more fearsome
enemies since form of many hybrid
creatures roaming the canyons of Mars
originally bio engineered by the first
settlers from the genetic makeup of
animals found on earth their notations
have since grown out of control the
harsh living conditions on Mars led
these creatures to develop effective
defense mechanism poison camouflage
brute force they will aggressively
defend their territory Shuji trespass
master one or all of the combat stances
staff blade with gun or mace with shield
each has its own skill tree where you
can improve your existing skills or gain
new ones by allocating XP you earn
during your retention the staff combat
is based on mobility and area damage
using sweet moves and glows effective
against groups of enemies fighting with
the blade in gun requires agility
careful dodging the blade can poison
enemies while the nail-gun lets you
control the pace of the Condor
finally the mason shield combat stance
focuses on defense
welcome to carrying the last second to
stagger enemies anything heavy gun it's
also important to remember you may
change stance during the fight let's not
forget you're a Technomancer
whichever combat stance you prefer you
can combine it with your electrical
powers Electrify your weapons to boost
its damage and disruption ability form a
magnetic shield around you to boost your
defense directly attack the powerful
arcs or enter overload your Tecna mercy
powers are what sets you apart and will
be an incredible asset in combat
your skills in combat will only get you
so far the crafting system will let you
upgrade your equipment thanks to spare
parts found while exploring looting from
enemies or salvaged from unwanted pieces
of gear you will be able to improve
damage resistance as well as at various
special effects such as disruption
resistance to specific damage types
energy regeneration and more improving
your crafting talent and learning new
construction plans will let you craft
more powerful gear the Technomancer
offers up to 40 hours worth of quests
most of which can be solved in different
ways here we're trying to meet the boss
of the very the problem is the door to
his office is guarded and their leader
won't let you enter without a pass you
can decide to simply force your way in
but you'll have to facing many owners at
once and a tough battle and it might
also degrade your reputation with the
boy you can also play the trick cards
stealing the required pass from a lone
guard to turn it in to the guard or take
a stealthy approach using your lock
picking of stealth skills to find
another way in
the quests in the technomancers I'll
often let you decide how to accomplish
them five different ways you'll be faced
with a lot of difficult decisions along
your journey and each of them will have
an impact on the world its inhabitants
your relationship with the factions at
play but also with your companions
eventually your choices and play style
will impact your story the fate of your
companions and the destiny of Mars and
its inhabitants all of your companions
have their own mood preferences and
moral code act too much against the
beliefs of one of them and they might
leave the group so be careful because
why your companions will be helpful
during the fights they also help you in
exploration with passive skills embark
upon your epic journey later this year
with the Technomancer
yes for Xbox one and PC
you